[Music]
two months after Chris Redfield and Jill
Valentine survived the original games
cause Resident Evil 2 you play as either
Claire Redfield on a mission to find her
brother or rookie cop Leon Kennedy on
his first and only dare in the Raccoon
City Police Department issue the t-virus
which was thought to have been
eradicated in the mansion incident has
reached Raccoon City which is now
infested with zombies not bear Lia and
Claire quickly discovered the chief of
police knew all about umbrellas
experiment and kept it quiet for
personal benefit as the story unfolds
Leon meets ADA Wong who is looking for
her boyfriend John and Claire meet
sherry the daughter of umbrella chief
scientists William and Annette Birkin I
found the girl
a secret bio lab is discovered which
holds the g-virus which unlike the
t-virus which turns its victims into
mindless zombies the g-virus has the
potential to create the ultimate
bio-organic weapon William Birkin has
decided to sell g-virus to the US
government after a disagreement with his
superiors causing umbrella to shut down
the program killing him and taken all
the g-virus samples in a last-gasp
effort to prolong his life Birkin
injects himself with his g-virus
creations it worked and Birkin survived
but his mind was no longer his own and
his body went through a few changes to
say the least
his main focus now is to find his
daughter and implant her with a G embryo
thus fulfilling the virus's need to
reproduce that's why he's after sherry
venturing further into umbrellas
underground facility Claire and Leon
battle zombies the freakishly terrifying
lickers and ivy plant a giant moth
cockroaches larvae and of course William
Birkin in his various g-virus it's to
make matters even worse depending on
your playthrough at1 or three tyrant
pursues our heroes throughout the entire
story Birkin finds his daughter and for
want of a better word in pregnant
sharing with the g-virus embryo he then
goes on to kill his own wife but not
before she can tell Claire how to create
a vaccine for sherry tell me what I need
to know Leon and ADA share a lovey-dovey
moment as she is revealed as a spy
attempting to steal the g-virus for an
unknown organized
somehow they are completely in love
after only spending ten minutes together
a true story of love at first sight Leon
and Claire create a vaccine for sherry
and save her like all against the
backdrop of the now famous resident evil
self destruction sequence finally Birkin
returns in his final fall but he's no
match for our heroes and Claire Leon and
sherry escape their nightmare to tie up
a few odds and ends
Claire continues her search for her
brother Leon is hired by the US
government and sherry well sherry story
will be further uncovered in Resident
Evil 6 so that's it
that's Resident Evil 2 in three minutes
with a little bit of the dark side
Chronicles thrown in for good measure if
you've enjoyed this please help our
channel grow by clicking the sub button
we've been looking at all major
installment in the Resident Evil
universe so please check out our videos
I'm Adam from blessed addition grenade
I'll see you next time
[Music]